well the current pandemic has focused an
awful lot of attention on something you
may have heard of but not known much
about the World Health Organization
that's the International Organization
that the US has quietly automatically
unthinkingly spent billions of dollars
supporting over the decades and most we
felt good about it but now is time to
ask the very reasonable question the
president is in fact asking what are we
getting for that support China spends
less than half as much as we do
supporting that w-h-o and it's clear
what they get they get a servile global
organization that is abetting their rise
to superpower status it's a pretty good
deal for them the waho excludes Taiwan
from membership
solely because Beijing has demanded that
they do that
cruelly by the way and from the start of
this pandemic the World Health
Organization has done shockingly little
to stop the virus from spreading around
the world in fact when the organization
appears in public at all it seems to be
functioning purely as an offshoot of
chinese state media Ted Ted rose at
Hannam who's the director of World
Health Organization has been there for
close to three years he was elected with
the support of China over the opposition
of the United States in late January Ted
Rose was gushing that China had
contained coronavirus in fact he said
China had set a standard that the rest
of the world are a copy the Chinese
government is to be congratulated for
the extraordinary measures it has taken
to contain the outbreak China is
actually setting a new standard for
outbreak response and it's not an
exaggeration all hail China Tetris was
so impressed by the Chinese government
so confident the corona virus was
defeated that he attacked other nations
for daring to take the racist step of
protecting themselves when the president
announced travel restrictions on China
in late January tendrá said that would
quote have the effect of increasing fear
and stigma with little public health
benefit end quote
On February 3rd he gushed about the
Chinese dictator ji and attacked any
notion of slowing down global travel or
trade I was so impressed in my meeting
with President
at his detailed knowledge of the
outbreak there is no reason for measures
that unnecessarily interfere with
international travel and trade well
that's just absolutely disgusting and
stupid and violates science and common
sense Tetris was completely wrong and
because he was wrong coronavirus became
a global calamity three weeks ago as one
country after there entered lockdown
Tedros told the world you should imitate
Wuhan Wuhan reported no new cases for
the first time since the outbreak
started one provides hope for the rest
of the world that even the most severe
situation can be turned around that's
one of the most corrupt displays
I think anyone's ever seen on tape of
course there are other countries wanted
to reduce their caseload they don't want
to take the World Health Organization's
advice just like the CDC in this country
w-h-o was pushing the absurd claim that
face max somehow don't work and are not
useful for containing the corona virus
China meanwhile the country that Tedros
never stops praising did not agree with
that in fact they were hoarding masks
they were doing it all the way back in
January in fact you start to wonder how
honest World Health Organization was
even giving that advice they also wonder
how honest doctor Ted Rose was only
warned against accelerating the use of
hydroxychloroquine to fight the virus
using untested medicines without the
right evidence could raise false hope
and even do more harm than good at this
point is pretty obvious this guy is
trying to hurt people
he runs the World Health Organization
and he's intentionally trying to hurt us
if you wanted an effective anti
coronavirus strategy you would just do
everything that Ted Rose tells you not
to
in fact that's been a pretty solid
position to take for a long time
before he ran the World Health
Organization Ted Russ was the Health
Minister of Ethiopia on three separate
occasions three that country was
ravished by cholera epidemics Tedros
lied about it he refused to minute was
happening insisted instead was just an
outbreak of quote acute watery diarrhea
hundreds died in those outbreaks which
were only accurately identified when
they spread into neighboring countries
in other words he lied on behalf of the
Ethiopian government which was worried
more about tourism and their reputation
than people surviving an epidemic then
he took over the World Health
Organization and Ted Rose vowed to crack
down on corruption at that organization
that hasn't happened to either
w-h-o still spends 200 million dollars a
year flying its staff around the world
often in business that's something other
health organizations banned their staff
from doing Doctors Without Borders would
never do something like that
corruption dishonesty cover-up shilling
for authoritarian dictatorships lying as
people die no wonder Ted Rose in China
are such profound allies fortunately
people are wising up to this even the
governor of New York Andrew Cuomo says
the World Health Organization should be
open to criticism where were the warning
signs who was supposed to blow the
whistle the president has asked this
question and I think he's right the
president's answer is the World Health
Organization should have been blowing
the whistle I don't I don't know enough
to know if that's right or wrong but I
know the question is right yeah the
question is certainly right and the
answer is very obvious they didn't blow
the whistle people died as a result and
they still get to run around calling
themselves the World Health Organization
why should we support corrupt
international organizations like this
that's not a partisan political issue
funding the w-h-o has only given us a
hostile dishonest bureaucracy that's
directly responsible for spreading this
pandemic we should get out of that
organization immediately and only fund
health organizations that help people
and prevent disease and by the way there
are a lot of them just not this one